not only did i lose my husband and four
children lose their dad
but we really lost an incredible mind
bob pape died from covid in september
last year
today over a hundred miles from home his
wife pays tribute
they were struggling they were so busy
and i think part of the problem was that
they were desperate to get people out so
you could get somebody else in indeed to
the fact when i called up and said why
was i told you wouldn't take bob back in
they said that either it was a temporary
worker or it was likely to be a change
in shifts and that there was nobody
there to deal with my inquiry
even the official memorial for those who
died from covid is in the south of the
country but a new report suggests it is
the north that was worst hit on many
fronts it says the rate of vaccination
was better in the north but that there
were 17 percent more coveted deaths
compared to the rest of england
in the north 10 percent more hospital
beds were occupied by covid patients
and on average people living in the
north had 41 more days of the harshest
lockdown restrictions
dr luke munford is one of the report's
authors and says it should be a wake-up
call during the pandemic there was
displacement of activity in hospitals
due to covert and again the north did
worse in other parts of the country so
there's a bigger backlog here and we
need to tackle that because if not then
this obviously will spill forward into
the future and these these inequalities
will continue to grow
this autumn the government is set to
publish a white paper which experts say
will finally set out policies to end
what the prime minister has called the
outrage of regional inequalities
researchers in the north of england say
health inequalities need to be addressed
as a top priority
the north also had higher unemployment
and wages that were already lower than
the rest of england fell further that's
our kind of contingency plan anna lost
the venue where she used to run her wine
bar it was a new business anyway i'd
only had it for a year and a half i was
really just finding my feet finding my
stride getting my name out there
and then
yeah just had no choice in getting it
taken away from you it's kind of
heartbreaking really anna now takes wine
direct to clients but the delivery she's
waiting for is from the government on
its two-year manifesto promise to level
up the country sadia chowdhury sky news
in manchester